devant l'entrée du lycée
hippolyte-fontaine une barricade et le
reste d'un container à déchets incendiés
sur des banderoles des appels à la grève
générale au-delà des questions lycéenne
celle l'ensemble de la politique
gouvernementale qui est dénoncée nous
dit-on à visage couvert se mobilisent
par rapport à parcours sup mais aussi
par rapport aux mouvements de grève
notamment des gilet jaune qu'on peut
voir en ce moment et qui au final est
une réforme de fond sur la société
nous sommes maintenant devant le lycée
bien montchapet un lycée bien où le
mouvement lycéen ici et bien a pas pris
à l'image d'ailleurs de la plupart des
établissements scolaires de
l'agglomération dijonnaise alors cela ne
veut pas dire pour autant que les cours
se déroulent normalement puisqu'il y
aurait un nombre important de
professeurs et bien grévistes combien
sont-ils exactement pour l'instant on ne
peut pas le savoir le rectorat ne
communiquera sur les chiffres qu'en
début d'après midi
et puis cet après-midi lira également
cette manifestation dans les rues de
dijon
alors combien y aura-t-il et bien
d'enseignants et de lycéens qui
participeront bien pour le savoir il
faudra attendre cet après midi